terrorisé par les bombardements comme
sur ces images à Kiev lundi
trimbalez sur les routes séparées de
leurs parents ou même des places de
forces par Moscou depuis le début de
l'invasion russe les enfants sont au
cœur de la guerre
l'Ukraine estime que plus de 16000
d'entre eux ont été envoyés de force en
Russie hier volo diverselenski a
inauguré à Kiev un centre de protection
de leurs droits afin d'aider les enfants
victimes ou témoins de crimes et de
ramener ceux qui ont été enlevés
j'espère que vous ramènerez tous les
enfants en Ukraine je soutiens
pleinement votre programme je veux que
les enfants reviennent tant qu'ils sont
encore enfants
ités cherchent à protéger les plus
jeunes hier la Russie a évacué les
enfants vivant à belgorodes une localité
frontalière de l'Ukraine intensivement
bombardée depuis quelques jours un
premier groupe d'entre eux a été envoyé
à 250 km au nord-est de la ville plus de
1000 mineurs doivent être encore évacués
vers d'autres provinces en mars
l'Ukraine estimait que près de 500
enfants avaient été tués depuis le début
de l'invasion russe le 24 février 2022
et la gare